this is amazing to be here I can't
believe this is my job this is what I do
for a living sometimes I think about
other jobs I could do for a living
beside this one my current favorite is I
want to run one of those gay conversion
therapy camps that's an amazing job guys
what do you even do you just take money
from terrible parents then provide a
safe place their kids to bang all summer
you know you guys have a good time knock
it out Don't Tell it out what happened
here we'll see you next summer all right
you guys are a fun crowd I like that I
feel like everything is so politically
divided now you know so it's nice to
have a fun crowd like we managed to get
into a controversy over the national
anthem somehow everyone asking who's
standing for the anthem who's kneeling
for the anthem no one asking the bigger
question why the countries even have
national anthems what why is every
country like a teenage couple like this
is our song we like it cuz it's about us
like countries don't need theme songs
guys especially gonna be so uptight
about it already stand up shut up take
your hat off our song is hon like relax
you don't even like the song you know
like you like it cuz it's your anthem
but you don't like the song it grows the
last time you put the national anthem on
a mixtape
no one's bumping it from their cars stop
it and of course you don't like it cuz
you never get to update it once you pick
a national anthem it's yours forever
we're stuck with the star-spangled
banner got an entire studio audience
anyone ever used the word spangled
before
Oh time for a new song I'm a word this
one all countries there we go and all
countries play their anthems at the
worst times like the Olympics when you
beat every country in the world at a
sport and then you're just bragging Oh
guess we're the fastest runners hey DJ
hey everybody stand up shut up
take your hat off our song isn't hard we
play it before sporting events in this
country I don't know why we do that
someone told me to remind us that we're
all American which is a nice sentiment
but we don't need a song to remind us
where American right we're ready at the
game with 40,000 other people who could
afford tickets getting drunk eating
fried food watching mostly people that
call or work on the field what could be
more historically American than that I
know we yell at them boohoo and we take
it even further than the national anthem
here we have the Pledge of Allegiance
every day we just make schoolchildren
profess their loyalty to the country how
thirsty are we how insecure you wouldn't
accept that at your spouse if they
wanted to do wedding vows every morning
no you psychopath I told you that I love
you stop it and these are
kindergarteners six years old I pledge
allegiance to the flag Lee what is the
allegiance of a six year old even worth
we're under attack from North Korea get
your flat jacket on Skyler front lines
what do you mean you want your mommy you
took a pledge get out there kids have
bigger problems to deal with man like
bullying in schools that's a big problem
a lot of people are on board to end it
more than you might think like I was at
a bookstore there was having a book
signing for an anti-bullying book there
was like a hundred and twenty people in
line to get their anti-bullying books
signed so I just cut to the front of the
line you know what are you [ __ ] gonna
do about it I just signed to copy myself
and flip the table and walked off it
made me think about how terrible
children's stories have always been like
everyone knows the ugly duckling right
what a terrible story that is for kids
we can't just teach them be nice to ugly
people because it's the right thing to
do instead we had to concoct a story
where the moral is be nice to ugly
people because they might be attractive
one day you could be making fun of a
future attractive person right now it's
no way to live your life there's a tough
time for kids growing up man everyone's
accusing everyone of being racist you're
there like racism is new like it's not
just baked into the cake of this country
so much so that we don't even notice it
anymore
you know like zoos or way to okay with
racism at zoos because every panda bear
at every zoo in this country is named
something like Bing Bing the Panda ding
ding some super racist Asian name that
is even a real Asian name it's like
something the bully in Mississippi calls
the one Chinese kid like shut up ping
ding nobody has
why are we naming pandas that they don't
know that they're from China they're
bears and just because they are you
don't to name them that I worked with
three Chinese people their names were
George Jenny and Edie what are we doing
it's so American to do that no way is
there zoo somewhere in China where they
have American grizzly bears and they're
like ladies and gentlemen welcome Derek
and Steve this is been amazing thank you
guys so much
you